the Senate Judiciary Committee will have
a final chance this morning to question
Supreme Court nominee Brett Kavanaugh
yesterday's marathon confirmation
hearing stretched late into the evening
the federal judge was pushed on issues
ranging from executive power to abortion
Jan Crawford watched all 12 hours he
joins us from inside the hearing room on
Capitol Hill so Jan after our 10:00 did
you think well but I'm sorry don't steal
that half hour difference I'm thinking
after our 10:00 did you think this is
gonna be a long night it was a long
night but you know what it was a lot
more civil in here yesterday than it was
on that first rocky day of hearings I
mean these Democratic senators grilled
cabin on all the major issues and he was
careful not to talk about any cases that
might come before him as a justice we
are a system of constitutional precedent
like nominees before him Judge Brett
Kavanaugh declined to discuss cases he
might decide as a justice I can't give
assurances on a specific hypothetical
avoiding detailed answers on topics
ranging from health care to affirmative
action you believe having a diverse
student body
he's a compelling government interest
the Supreme Court has said so he said he
understood the real-world consequences
of the courts decisions and on abortion
he tried to show compassion I understand
the importance that people attached to
the roe v wade decision but he distanced
himself from the president's promises on
judicial nominees his litmus test for
that list was that a justice that he'd
nominate would have to automatically
overturn roe v wade correct I'm not
gonna comment on what he had said
whatever he publicly he said it my
position as a judge is that there's 45
years of precedent the 12 and a half
hour hearing featured dozens of
interruptions and numerous questions by
senators from both parties on the power
of the presidency I worried that the
president the head of our executive
branch may be using executive power to
advance personal political interests I
don't think we want judges
commenting on the latest political
controversy because that would
ultimately lead the people to doubt
whether we're independent now late last
night senators Booker and Harris
questioned Cavanaugh about issues of
race and he said he was proud of his
record on diversity but he knows the
country has a lot more work to do on
issues of race discrimination Nora was
fascinating Jim thank you so much